[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everybody I'm Brian Lehrer from wmic
thank you so much for coming tonight
wasn't that dance number sweet I loved
how the robot manipulated the human into
thinking she was still relevant no
that's not what it was about oh I'm
sorry I was specially impressed that the
robot fell on its nose something it
might have learned from me watching when
I was out running in Queens last weekend
and then splat I figured I should just
explain why it came out with bandages on
my nose and that's why so maybe what it
means to be human is that when we get
injured in a visible way we get
self-conscious about it while other
species don't my mother says the upside
of my injury is that now I can get a
nose job and insurance will cover it
which means my mother was self-conscious
about my nose even before I got hurt we
are very human we humans before we get
out I'll bring out our guests I thought
maybe you all might like to get to know
a little bit who's here in the audience
with you how many of you work in any
field you would call the sciences so
those are the obsessed people who can't
get enough
how about humanities or the arts the
well-rounded contingent this year
business anyone work in business I won't
tell your colleagues on Monday I promise
and what about crime who here works as a
criminal
just making sure you were all human
enough to lie and not raise your hand if
that describes you for all the Charles
Darwin contributed to our modern
understanding of the biological world
one puzzling question which he
ultimately posed as an open research
question to the scientific community
nagged him until the day he died how did
the incremental process of evolution by
natural selection
suddenly produce an utterly
unprecedented kind of animal such as
humans this program will examine from a
variety of perspectives what it means to
be human so now I'm going to introduce
the participants our first participant
is a professor of anthropology at
Florida State University she's done
research on primate brains and
prehistoric human relatives including
Albert Einstein's brain and the skeletal
remains of an eighteen thousand year old
hobbit-sized human welcome Dean fog
our our next participant is a professor
of psychology at Harvard University he
is an experimental psychologist
cognitive scientists linguist and one of
the foremost writers on language mind
and human nature Steven Pinker
[Applause]
[Music]
also with us tonight is an associate
professor in the department of
biochemistry and cell biology at Stony
Brook University he has worked on the
human uniqueness problem for over 25
years and he co-authored the book death
from a distance and the birth of a
humane universe welcome Paul Bingham
thank you and our final participant a
paleoanthropologist researcher and
Explorer his explorations into human
origins on the African continent Asia
and Micronesia have resulted in many new
discoveries including the most complete
early hominid fossils ever discovered
welcome Lee Berger all four of our
participants have different theories
we'll see how they intersect and don't
and Dean I gather you're gonna start by
taking us back 3.5 million years yes
thank you I'm very glad to be here
tonight I do want to begin 3.5 million
years ago and look initially at what
archeologists have found in the fossil
record and the that relates to material
culture and technology and if you go to
the left there that little hominin is
3.3 million years old from Ethiopia and
you might recognize the fellow on the
right he died in 1955 and what I'd like
you to notice is a material culture in
between three point three million years
ago we have the first known stone tools
that were deliberately made and for a
long time after that what you have in
the material record are rocks they get
better they get smaller and more
modified but as you come up to the
present you get your wonderful art much
more recently and then today you know we
have dancing robots
so the question is tonight how did we
get from the rocks to the dancing robots
and I think it was to do with brain
evolution and so what I'd like you to
notice now is we're going to see brain
size coming in across here so brain size
got bigger and as it got bigger it
became modified and reorganized and
rewired and we know that by comparing
brains of humans with non-human primates
we know the size got bigger by looking
at fossils now ever since at least
Darwin people have wondered well who's
responsible and what was responsible for
this remarkable evolution and there have
been a number of theories a few which
are very well known one is this is from
the 1960s man the hunter and it's still
in textbooks it's been very very
dominant but within a decade
there was another alternative proposed
by some of my colleagues who it will not
surprise you were many of them women
women the gather and there's no doubt
that hunting and gathering were
extraordinarily important during our
evolution because that's how our
ancestors made their living up until
about 12,000 years ago
so for millions of years they did this
but I don't think hunting and gathering
were the thing that moved along brain
evolution and so tonight I'm going to
propose someone else
baby the trendsetter and specifically
I'd like to suggest three trends in
chronological order that happens in
natural selection on infants very young
infants even fetuses and to do that we
have to go back another three and a half
million years even earlier and look at
the origins of walking on two legs or
bipedalism and so what we have here is a
nifty animation of a quadruped ed
becoming bipedal and the colored part is
the pelvis that becomes modified and
becomes essentially a constricted
and millions of years after this that
will be a problem for giving birth it's
called the obstetric dilemma but we
won't see that problem this far back in
time but let's play this again and look
at the feet so our ancestors maybe as
long ago as 7 million years became
upright walkers and it completely
modified the body and it changed posture
and locomotion that foot seems to be a
grasping instrument and became a
weight-bearing instrument and this is
where we get the first trend of three
trends in baby the trend setter which is
a trend for being a late bloomer so to
look at these trends we compare we look
in the fossil record but then we compare
living humans with living chimpanzees
and so you have the direct and the
comparative evidence and we know if you
see all of the monkeys and the Apes the
children or the infant's grow up very
quickly they develop all the milestones
can hold up their head can crawl
eventually stand very quickly human
infants are slow their late bloomers
they're slow developers and one of the
most dramatic things that happen as a
result of that is that unlike all of the
other higher primates our our infant's
lost the ability to cling 24/7 to their
mothers the monkeys and apes those
babies are born helpless but very soon
in their life they can hang on to their
infants and during evolution there was a
reversal so our babies can't do that
they want to hang on but they can't so
there was a trend to seek contact
Comfort and you see over in the right
you see the infant crying and another
one gesturing to be picked up and these
are advanced trends that evolved humans
cry in a unique way that babies have
emotional tears and a lot of this
studies have shown is because they want
the contact comfort with their
caretakers with their mothers and we see
evolution today that shows this trend
which we still have and when you give
babies pacifiers or blank
'if you are satisfying their need for
contact comfort and that they inherited
from their ancestors
we also jiggle them and bounce them up
and down and that simulates contact with
being with the mother being carried
along so again you can see the day out
there in the world evolution beam why do
you think the reversal in evolution
happened and maybe talk a little bit
more about what you mean by reversal and
what would have been adaptive about that
- what kinds of conditions at that time
okay I think it happened because with
bipedal isn't the entire motor system
rearranged and it wasn't just feet hands
are genetically linked and posture and
so babies became Health helped us in
terms of locomotion not other things so
much and they lost that ability to cling
to the to the moms and as a result of
that it opened up I think a vocal
channel between mothers and infants and
we have we see this today - we have
mother Eve which is an evolved thing the
other primates don't do it they might
have contact calls but with human
species you know all over the world
parents from when the baby's born they
speak to in baby-talk
and it's incessant and that is a derives
a drive advanced feature and it's very
important for the acquisition of
language in the infant's this eye leads
to the third trend I call it the brain
spurt and to do this we were comparing
humans with chimpanzees and you're
seeing a graph here of individuals
growing up and what happens to brain
size in the chimp at the bottom one that
brain size you know this levels off
pretty soon with the human there's a
spurt of brain growth in that first year
and actually prenatally that lifts that
graph higher and higher so humans end up
as adults with brains that are three to
four sizes the brains of the chimpanzees
if you look in the fossil record
this is one fossil it's an infant from
about two two-and-a-half million years
ago and you can see its trend is higher
than the chimps and if we were to put
other fossils on there through time you
if you went up for instance to Homo
erectus which is much more recently you
would see that curved lift higher and
higher so this brainy spurt in infants
it was responsible I think for the
evolution of brain size during hominid
evolution and if we want to know what
that was about we have to ask well
what's happening to that human brain
prenatally and very early on that's not
happening to the chimp ring beginning in
the last trimester fetuses are tuning in
to what they're hearing and they're
specifically interested in and tuning in
to their mothers voices that's being
filtered in the womb and their brains
are becoming programmed for being
receptive when they're born for language
once they're born they on their busy
pattern processing both the the sounds
and vision and it's aimed at or it's
directed at a language acquisition
babies when they're six months old can
hear the distinction in all of the
world's languages they can hear about
800 speech sounds by the time they're
one year the connections in the brain
have both increased and decreased so
that they narrow in on about 40 sounds
in their native languages so I think
that when we ask about in evolution what
was responsible for this I think
language was very important because the
kind of processing that goes on these
networks that become widely distributed
are also accessible then for other kinds
of activities like dancing robots but
you need I think have the language first
and then that wiring is available or was
available I do think that it was
probably language because that's what's
going on during that brains
they're not hunting they're not
gathering they're not making tools
they're getting language and that is an
either-or theory you think it's not kind
of all of those things a good question I
think probably language with primary and
that once that machineries there you get
all that other stuff all right steven
pinker do you enter through the
cognitive niche yes yeah the the first
thing we have to explain about our
species is why we are so deeply weird
biological standards now there's a lot
of debate I think often rabbinical and
pointless over whether humans are unique
whether you know our language whether
the dance of the bees ought to be
considered a language and whether a crow
puts a stick in its mouth that counts as
tool use and I usually stay away from
debates over definitions or Rubicon's or
dividing lines but if you just look at
the extent to which humans do humanly
unusual things and the collection of
them that you all find in one species
you see that we're we're very unusual to
begin with and the most salient to me as
a psycho linguist we talk I mean here we
are we're gonna sit in this room for a
couple of hours just listening to each
other make noise as we exhale very very
few species that would do that and
language has universally a number of
rather remarkable properties we can use
arbitrary signs to refer to tens of
thousands of objects and actions and
places in the world and we can combine
them grammatically so that the meaning
of the combination can be computed from
the meanings of the individual signs and
that the way they're arranged but I
don't think that language is the only
thing that differentiates us from other
species I think if you just graft of
language on to a chimp it wouldn't have
anything particularly interesting to say
and so I think that that language has to
be understood in the context of other
weird traits of Homo sapiens another one
is our
yes when is our reliance on on artifacts
and technology and tools look around
everything that we are now seeing was
made by an ensemble of humans is nothing
but in its natural state in this room
and again universally humans not only
making use tools but they make a use of
variety of them each tool is made out of
a variety of parts requires a laborious
process of manufacture and most
important we co-evolved with our tools
if you we depend on them for our
survival you take away the technology of
any human group and and it would quickly
starve the third ZOA logically unusual
trait of humans is that we cooperate
with people who aren't related to us to
us if you were to put several hundred
chimpanzees into a room like this half
of the male then riot would break out
but but humans do in addition to the
tens of thousands of people that have to
cooperate to make all of the things that
we see we sit quietly in order to
achieve some something that benefits all
of us and again it's very hard to see
examples of cooperation for mutual
benefit among unrelated organisms so how
do we explain what there at that part if
I could ask would that but not be also
found in things like bees to use your
example or no these are ladies they're
not only er bees related they're highly
related I mean because of their unusual
genetic system more related than than
been even siblings a lot of are related
by sharing three-quarters of their genes
so bees would be a case of cooperation
mediated by genetic relatedness and
asked to dependent I think depends on
the species but yeah so and their other
unusual features of mrs. Dean mentioned
we have long helpless childhoods we have
long lives the male's invest in their
offspring
parents invest in their offspring we
have very we have weird sex lives with
lots of sex that's not reproductive and
negotiated and varying from one group to
another in turn it's customs we eat
everything were found in every
ecological system on earth from from the
Arctic to the tropics so there's no
question that we're a weird species and
we need an explanation yeah I don't
think at there other weird species it's
not an evolutionary miracle the
elephants are weird in their ways and
whales and blue-green algae and so on so
I don't think we need anything exotic
but we do have to explain what led to
the coevolution of a number of unusual
traits that are all found in the same
species my favorite idea comes from a
concept originated by john tooby and
herb Devore I'm hoping if I repeat it
enough times people will forget that I
think that I came up with it but that I
will mention that they deserve the
credit and think they call it fate the
cognitive niche and it starts from the
observation but the commonplace
observation that in evolution organisms
evolve at each other's expense so with
the exception of fruit every food item
for every organism is the body part of
some other organism which would just
assume keep that body part for itself
and so all organisms need defenses
against being eaten shells weapons
poisons stealth camouflage in the case
of plants chemical warfare irritants and
poisons and bitter tasting substances
which sets the stage for offensive
weaponry to defeat the defenses that
organisms have against be eaten more
acute perceptual systems speed stealth
weapons you know call evolutionary arms
race
now what's unusual about humans is that
we kind of cheat in this arms race by
developing ways of defeating the
defenses of other organisms not over
evolutionary time generation by
generation but in real time in our own
lifetimes by developing mental models of
the environment
caused an effect texture of the world
around us and manipulating it to our
advantage we develop traps that rely on
laws of physics on expectations of
animal behavior on our intuitions about
biology we extract poisons from one
organism and use them against another we
defeat the defences of plants by boiling
or fermenting or peeling or cooking and
therefore enjoy plant nutrients and all
of it done faster than other organisms
can develop defenses in their turn
because we do it in our heads and by
exchanging ideas with one another which
is why whenever humans enter a habitat
the other species drop like flies if you
look at talk about definitions of our
species if you look up man in ambrose
bierce is the devil's dictionary the
definition indicates that our chief
occupation is the extermination of other
species and each other
however we reproduce with such insistent
rapidity as to infest the entire
habitable earth and Canada I think kind
of CAP captures our species and I think
it explains the why the that entire
complex of ZOA logically unusual traits
is found in the same species because
each one of them multiplies the value of
the others most obviously there's
technology which depends on our
intuitive understanding of the
environment what breaks what bends what
Falls what rolls and that depends on our
intuitions of physics of forces and
objects and substances our intuitions of
living things of organisms that have
essences that are responsible for their
powers I think it accounts for our
language that if we have accumulated
technological know-how that gives us
something to talk about something to
share and it means that we can profit we
don't have to as they say
reinvent the wheel but we can profit
from all of the strokes of genius and
trial and error and accumulated wisdom
of other members of our species but only
if we're cooperating with them that is
only if we have something to offer in
the expectation of a return farther down
the line and of course language is also
the medium by which we can negotiate
reciprocal exchanges we don't just have
to exchange you know meat for fruits or
or groom one I groom you then you groom
groom me with language we can say I'll
do you this favor now but you know as
with the the opening scene of The
Godfather the there there will be a day
and that day may never come where I will
ask a favor of you and I expect you to
remember what I did for you today
something that you can only do with
language the thing about language is
that it exchanges a unusual commodity
information that's unlike other trade
goods because it can be multiplied at
virtually no cost if I give you a fish I
no longer have the fish but if I teach
you how to fish then it's not as if I'm
now I'm music for the ability to fish we
both can have it I've made a copy of it
and information can exist in any number
of copies which makes it a perfect trade
good because the theoreticians who try
to explain the evolution of reciprocal
altruism say that it's powered by the
ability to confer a large benefit to
someone else at a small cost to oneself
which is what makes the reciprocal
exchange mutually benefit beneficial
information has that property language
is an efficient way of exchanging
information if you're on speaking terms
so all three of them I think reinforce
the other two so it sounds like you're
describing some of the characteristics
of human uniqueness how much would you
say the cognitive niche might come from
baby the trendsetter the Dean was
talking about how much do you overlap in
this and how
much are they mutually exclusive yeah
III think there is overlap I would have
less confidence in singling out one part
of this complex as the the first domino
but but I do think they all reinforce
each other and certainly our long you
can think of our what why does our
species have this long helpless
childhood well it's a in part it's an
apprenticeship we depend more than other
species on acquired know-how uh it
before we strike out on our own
reproductive career there's a lot to
learn and so we are helpless for a long
period of time just to acquire in our
lifetimes the kind of survival skills
that other animals are more likely to
have pre-programmed
thank you very much Steven Pinker so
Paul Bingham tell me how a molecular
biologist doing research into the
treatment of cancer got involved in this
area where as you put it to me backstage
what's a nice molecular biologist like
you doing in a place like this I
actually trained with the generation of
people who develop contemporary
molecular biology matt meselson Jim
Watson Francis Crick and my scientific
grandfather was Linus Pauling and and
from those people I learned the
importance of really good theory but
also the importance of waiting to attack
a question until it was within reach but
what happened in the late around 1980s
we began to see where the answer to the
human uniqueness question might lie and
that brought us into this domain as
natural scientists bringing the tools of
natural sciences into the project I
should emphasize before I began that
there are two other crucial
collaborators in this project one is
Professor Joanne Souza at Stony Brook
University as psychologist who's been
involved in every aspect of this project
for over a decade and professor daijiro
Okada originally at the Institute for
Advanced Study at Princeton now at UPenn
a game theorist and economist who helped
us develop the technical game theory
that underlies the stories that we're
going to talk about in the next few
minutes so what we set out to do was to
develop what's called a parsimonious
theory in the jargon of the Natural
Sciences that's a theory that's simple
on the one hand and yet predicts a lot
in detail
these theories are really useful for two
reasons one is that they're powerful
they let you predict and understand
things ostensibly including human
uniqueness in human nature they're also
useful for another reason because they
make lots of predictions and are
therefore easily testable if they're
wrong you can tell quickly and if
they're right you begin to get an idea
that you're correct the theory that we
have developed is referred to now as
social coercion theory and I want to
outline it for you in the next few
minutes it appears to be one of these
highly parsimonious accounts of some of
the things that we've just been hearing
about it of course it will be very
interesting to hear Dean and Stevens
reaction citizen so before I begin
taking you through the details of the
theory let me start right at the
beginning by emphasizing that a lot of
people are looking for the origins of
human uniqueness in the emergence of
modern humans symbolized by the image
right here very recently let's say in
the last 50,000 years on social horrors
in theory we believe human this has much
greater time depth than that 1.6 to 1.8
million years at least and it follows
for example that Neanderthals and modern
humans who coexist at 50,000 years ago
were equivalently human by any
reasonable measurement and we argue that
our ancestors largely displaced
Neanderthals as a result of a particular
kind of social accident that we're going
to return to in just a couple of minutes
okay so to understand social coercion
theory we have to begin at a well
documented in fundamental fact about the
world all non-kin individual animals
have conflicts of interest that's
symbolized by the fighting individuals
here humans are unique because we are
the first animal to control those
conflicts of interest moreover we do
this in a simple specific universal way
through the present instant as
illustrated on this slide we
we take advantage of the capacity of
projectile weapons to allow large
cooperative coalition's to inexpensively
project overwhelming coercive threat
against what game theorists call Free
Riders social parasites non co-operators
as a result in us for the first time in
history of life on earth cooperation
between non kin becomes police about an
therefore a Darwinian adaptation this as
you'll see in the next couple of minutes
is a revolutionary transition of course
guns are a very recent invention we
believe that that practical projectile
weapons became available to our
ancestors for the first time as the
result of the evolution of elite aimed
throwing so humans throw with the same
kind of virtuosity that a dolphin swims
or a cheetah runs our minds and bodies
have clearly been redesigned for this
specific behavior moreover there's sound
evidence which prefer perhaps we can
discuss later that elite throwing is at
least 1.6 to 1.8 million years old now
at first glance of course it's a little
disturbing that our access to
inexpensive social coercive violence is
the origin of our uniqueness but let me
argue to you that there is a
diametrically opposite and very
important perspective to take in us the
humane cooperation is a Darwinian
adaptation because of the parallel
Darwinian capacity to coercively
suppressed inhumane behavior so we argue
that the evolution of elite throwing is
the ultimate cause of all of the other
properties a few million acres that
we've been hearing about tonight and so
let me actually walk you through some of
the some of those stories so this slide
emphasizes what Dean told us about a
moment ago the dramatic expansion of
that brain size in our lineage to
understand this we have to begin
someplace a little unexpected with
culturally transmitted information
culturally transmitted information is
very useful if true but potentially
false so its transmission between non
kin individuals creates a powerful
conflict of interest and an animal can
evolve to exchange cultural information
between
can only if it can manage that conflict
of interest ancestral hominids had the
capacity to coercively ostracize liars
and tools and then that kind of
environment truth-telling and the
transmission of cultural information now
becomes an adaptive Enterprise as a
result of this massively expanded stream
of cultural information we are of course
obviously the cultural information the
cultural animal as Steven mentioned a
moment ago but this creates an adaptive
benefit to expanding the expensive
neural tissue that stores and processes
that all all that information giving us
brain expansion moreover we expect the
brain to be redesigned systematically to
deal with all this information in
diverse ways including the evolution of
elite linguistic behavior the
quintessential talent for transmitting
information
moreover we expect us of course to be
the pedagogical animal to spend all of
the time that we've talked about
absorbing this information we also
predict that we should be the economic
animal we have access to enormous
amounts of information but we can't know
everything so in fact there's enormous
individual adaptive benefit in
exchanging the fruits of individually
specialized culturally transmitted
expertise that we hold with others who
hold different expertise of course this
creates a conflict of interest problem
the exchange of valuable things creates
a conflict of interest problem and only
in an animal that can coercively enforce
some form of property law can the act
then can economic behavior emerge our
status is the economic animal is going
to be very important in a few minutes as
we understand how we got to be so
ascendant over the last few thousand
years we'll call that back in just a
moment
we also expect that we should be the
moral animal in a very specific sense
our ethical psychology should look like
approximate device to mobilize our
participation in conjoint coercive
threat moral outrage looks very much
like that we should also evolve to
engage in cooperative activities that
depend on this coercively enforced moral
environment as in fact we do there's one
last prediction that's less obvious but
extremely important we should be are
predicted to be the radically Democrat
mechanimal throughout most of our 1.8
million year evolution as humans the
coercive weapons that were available to
us were inherently broadly distributed
coercive threat was democratically owned
very recently just about 5,500 years ago
new technical developments allow the
invention of weapons body armor and
shock weapons in particular that tended
to concentrate course decisive course of
threat in the hands of small militarized
male coalitions elites unfortunately the
social units resulting from that what
archaeologists call archaic States
invented written language so when we
first started investigating this new
home Union union's problem a few hundred
years ago the oldest evidence we had
indicated that hierarchical patrimony
was the natural human condition that's
almost certainly false and misleading we
are in fact almost certainly a radically
democratic animal by biological nature
that's also very important we'll call it
back in a few minutes so these specific
predictions sort of illuminate the way
in which we can understand social core
human uniqueness as emerging simply from
the evolution of social coercion but in
fact we they and they give us insight
into the human condition human nature
but we're more confident than just that
that the theory is likely to be right
because it spins out the first broadly
general theory of history that we've
ever had and of course the good theory
of history is valuable because it's also
a theory of the present in the future if
it's right so I want correct write that
clarify a few things did you say a bit
ago that militarization led to speech
and language no well it depends on what
you mean by militarization democratized
forces threat ancient 1.62 1.8 million
years ago allow the emergence of kinship
independent social cooperation with all
of its features including the expansion
of culturally transmitted information
the evolution of language to transmit
that and if we are coercive animals yes
then why would we also be moral or
radically democratic
animals Stephen said before if this was
a roomful of chimps riot would break out
and then presumably the most dominant
and successful ones would you know scare
away the others for the future and
coercion would have taken place in that
species right so there are a lot of
different ways to answer that question
in arriving at the same place but so it
turns out that in non-human animals who
don't have this capacity for conjoint
projection of threat decisive threat is
in the hands of dominant individuals
large and powerful individuals but
because of the effect of numerical
advantage in the use of projectile
weapons power doesn't lie with large
individuals it allows it lies with
numerical majorities it power exists in
numbers so in fact we can only be
powerful as humans if we are members of
a majority coalition so we are coercive
but we're coercive of humane behavior in
one another property behaviorist even if
I heard you correctly it was that the
first large hierarchical States were
also the ones that develop written
language not language I'm sorry I should
have hammered the word written Yeah
right but that turns out to be really
important right because history is the
line made up by the winner so in point
of fact the in point of fact this
written history appeared to present
elite patrimony patriarchy as the
natural condition and we're arguing that
that is most emphatically very unlikely
to be true and a few mins learn to
control conflict of interest how do you
explain Albany sorry I couldn't resist
what Steven mentioned the importance of
arms race is evolutionary arms races
so our control of the conflict of
interest problem is constantly being
subverted by interest groups and it's a
it's a constant back and forth in our
ability to manage that so in fact as I
alluded to a moment ago we also get a
theory of history that emerges from
social coercion theory let me take the
last couple of minutes to outline that
for you because it's extraordinarily
important we believe so human adaptive
sophistication is actually no longer
really limited by our individual
intelligence it's limited by the scale
in which we can engage in economic
cooperation the number of specialists
within our cooperative groups however
the size of our social cooperative
groups is absolutely limited inevitably
by the scale on which we can police the
conflict-of-interest problem thus our
human history is predicted to look and
does look as follows humans acquire the
scale of cooperation permitted by the
course of technologies they possess and
then acquire the adaptive sophistication
associated with that scale and then
remain at that adaptive sophistication
sometimes for very long periods of time
however for one reason or another
ultimately a new weapon is invented
allowing an expanded scale of policing
of social cooperation and a new adaptive
revolution rapidly ensues and in fact
this happens over and over has happened
over and over again in our history so I
alluded before to the social accident of
the triumphs of our modern ancestors
over Neanderthals there's good reason to
believe that that is the result of
modern humans inventing a weapon called
the OP model - the spear thrower which
substantially expanded their extent of
their coercive range expanded their
social cooperation and then they rolled
over Neanderthals for the same reason
that European states rolled over
Neolithic Native Americans not because
they were genetically superior but
because the scale of their social
cooperation was greater this image is
intended to stand in for the
agricultural revolutions another set of
adaptive revolutions there's very good
evidence in Eurasia in particular that
the invention of the bow gradually
spreads across Eurasia and in its wake
numerous agricultural revolutions ensue
in the interest of time let me skip the
archaic state which we already talked
about a moment ago and proceed directly
to the modern state that you and I think
of as the natural condition with the
invention and refinement of gunpowder
weaponry it became possible to stabili
consolidate the state initially and then
ultimately to redistribute access to
course its threat democratically
this creates now something fundamentally
new in human history a social unit that
practices the ancient human art of
democratic cooperation but does so on
the massive new scale of the state we
predict and observe an adaptive
revolution so for example you and I are
about a hundred times richer than our
medieval peasant ancestors of just a
couple of hundred
ago and indeed the Scientific Revolution
unfolds the Industrial Revolution
unfolds at this same time in just the
last couple of generations in living
memory we have for the first time
acquired the capacity to project
coercive threat on a planetary scale as
a result of this development we now
police in a kind of rough way in the
ancient ancestral human way a global
cooperation the threat of world war is
predictably receding as a result thus we
are now irrevocably joined in a enormous
coalition of seven billion people and
growing the opportunities for human
enrichment at this scale are enormous as
are the dangers so for example we now
have global financial markets that can
empower massive projects that are highly
vulnerable to elite manipulation and
catastrophic instability we can also
prosecute science on a global scale
represented here by the Hubble telescope
and are therefore peeling the layers off
the physical universe at a gallop the
challenge of course is to use all of
this new information sustainably and
adaptively we are now locked irrevocably
in an exponentially accelerating race
between our knowledge and our wisdom I
think an opinion that probably we would
all share on this stage is that one of
the single most important pieces of
knowledge we need in order to have the
wisdom to build a humane future for all
of the world's descendants is to
understand our evolutionary origins and
its implications for our behavior all of
us on this stage and the communities of
which we are members are working
assiduously to try to provide that
knowledge now you come up with a
percentage chance that humans are doomed
to destroy ourselves through our wisdom
being right but insufficient to our
knowledge well as Yogi Berra famously
said predictions are hard especially
about the future but they I think that
we I think I'm actually relatively
optimistic I think the likelihood that
we perish from thermo nuclear holocaust
for example is extremely low
I think it's more like because in fact
we are who have two million years of
experience dealing with course if
weapons we're good at not overstepping
their limits
the real danger of course is that we
inadvertently destabilize global climate
and don't realize it until it's too late
our adaptive power makes us very
vulnerable to that end thank you
Lee burger you've been doing new
research I know in recent years on human
uniqueness have you views been changing
very much well what was ironic when I
was asked to be a participant in this
planet of the humans
was it struck me immediately that well
unlike Stephen science my science of
paleoanthropology and the biological
origins of humans is obsessed with
definitions and Rubicon's
we have spent a great deal of our time
defining what it is to be a species and
setting points of moment that we're
extraordinary in the past what might
surprise this audience although all of
us have been speaking sort of Glivec
glibly about the obvious nosov human
uniqueness is that there is no real
biological definition of what it is to
be a human we don't have the fine
definition in place that allows us to
readily say that's a human and in the
fossil record this is not a human what
happened in the Victorian era when we
first began to examine our sort of
origins was it was very easy religious
texts told us what it was to be a human
and we were separate from the world we
were separate from the animal world we
were different in very obvious ways we
stood upright we were more complex we
had spirituality we had tools that no
other animal seemed to come near we had
all the physical features that were all
aware of a large brain small teeth we
could compare ourselves and Darwin even
notices to what he presumed were our
closest living relatives in Africa but
clearly that difference was substantive
it was obvious and it didn't need
defining it was already manifestly
defined in our
history then we began to find fossils
now very luckily they fit our
preconceived ideas in the order in which
they were found and in our expectations
of human uniqueness the first ones being
found in Europe or large brain but what
we would consider crude and primitive in
the form of the early Neanderthals that
was followed by faux fossils which fit
our preconceived ideas even better we
even invented them and Piltdown which
actually led us to the obvious
conclusion that all the important events
in human evolution had happened where
the highest states of civilization are
places like Europe and so we had
actually manufactured a fossil record
that agreed with our ourselves then we
moved that story to Africa in 1924 the
discovery of the Tong job that was a
small-brained it looked like a biped so
it seemed to separate itself out from
the world and the fossils that would
follow would as they began to gain
acceptance show the kind of just so
stories that fit the idea of human
uniqueness we would see faces low level
of brain increased through time
eventually we would end up with this
large special human brain that went
through a series of transitions that
were pretty much along the storyline we
found out that bipedalism was deep time
and utterly made us unique from all
other primates and even human level
bipedalism when fossils like Lucy came
on to the stage it seemed to cement the
idea that there it was we were erect and
the our hands we could see were
prehensile adapted to tools and even the
archaeological record supported that we
could see that as those changes occurred
the idea that brain size increased the
hands altered that tools appears so
that's why Homo habilis was called
handyman in in the beginning of the
first idea of the earliest members of
our genus that would lead to a
progression that we would we would find
so clearly to have us ask questions of
modernity the idea of what does it mean
to be a modern human in that very
definition saying that well there's
something different between those of us
today
and those things that might have looked
like us but clearly aren't us is that
sort of uniqueness that everyone alludes
to right now if you look at textbooks or
the archaeological record it'll tell you
that it's accompanied by some things
that are happening probably between a
hundred and two hundred thousand years
ago closer to a hundred and two hundred
thousand that fits really well with
genetic evidence which is arguing that
all of our we all share very narrow
genetic identity appearing just about it
that time period that's tied to things
like adornment the first art that we're
now seen in places like where I work in
southern Africa that appears to be tied
to perhaps humans seeing themselves as
special in nature and that might
manifest is burial of the dead except
are leading up to what is an on
definition of humans that is obvious
it's obvious when we see one we just
don't know how to put all that together
and as Stephen and I were talking before
this discussion maybe it's just all of
those but the problem with that is
that's really moving right back to where
we were in the Victorian era we can see
it but we can't test it we can't
formulate a hypothesis to test it but we
need that hypothesis because that neat
little story that I was just telling
that we kind of saw through a broad
timeline of a few million years as as we
as we deliberate it is falling apart
those sacred cows are dying particularly
the last 15 years as what was a
incredibly fragmentary small fossil
record paleoanthropology is one of the
unusual Sciences that up until recently
we could probably claim that we had more
scientists than we had objects to stay
and that probably tells you more about
the people who study this sort of thing
than it does about the positive of the
record but as the fossil record has
exploded and quite literally the numbers
are doubling on almost a yearly basis
now on the continent of Africa as we
begin to expand our exploration programs
those sacred cows are dying just
recently with our deepest thickest
ramidus we realize that that bipedalism
may have other definitions than this
sort of simplified version that we see
here have elongated legs and and the
changes in structure to our pelvis and
our foot and that words like facultative
bipedalism come into the record that
brain size and and those moments of
shift and brain size may be either
didn't occur at all or we're not
necessarily important for changes things
like Australopithecus sediba which my
team and I described a few years ago has
a small brain but reorganization appears
to be taking place things like the
Flores Hobbit so that many of you might
have heard of this small contentious
member of the genus homo on the island
of Flores dating to maybe fifty ninety
thousand years or something like this is
clearly in our genus with a tiny brain
the size of a chimpanzee but capable of
complex activities so that brain size
argument may actually fall away or be
slaughtered along with others we're
seeing different sorts of of
manipulative abilities that are not all
the same in the hands and we can go
right through the body and see each one
of these things harder so all we're
really left with are just a few things
in nineteen in the 1950s Jane Goodall
brought us a little closer to the animal
kingdom she found out that chimpanzees
iya stools struck every one is
remarkable and so from that Victorian
perspective perhaps brought us to here
as all of these sort of sacred cows have
died we've been brought closer and
closer till today we are possibly only
left with the different ation between us
in the animal kingdom with those things
that we talk about to identify modernity
art prayer
it's self adornment perhaps burial of
the dead indicating we're special in
nature and I have a prediction for you
everyone here that's probably a little
more than a prediction I wouldn't hold
on to all those things either because
what we're now seeing as we begin to
actually explore Africa the old world
other places those sacred cows are
probably all going to die and it's gonna
be a very interesting moment for us as
we seek a definition within our field of
what is it to be human when there's
nothing left that makes us actually
unique but if you are arguing that human
uniqueness doesn't exist you mentioned
in your talk a couple of things
spirituality the ability to ask what
does it mean to be a modern human and
know what that means
wouldn't those things be unique to human
beings well they are right now they are
at least by the the the sort of
superficial definition that we see but
we don't know where they begin you've
heard that you've heard that Paul is
talking back perhaps there are things
beginning two million years where does
language begin and what would it mean I
would pose you what would happen opposed
to anyone what would happen if we found
another species of non-human animal that
practiced those things okay it's the
Star Trek question right it's the idea
of how do you meet an alien in what
would we do because with all these other
biological morphological archaeological
behaviors falling away have we reached a
point where the definition of well we
can just recognize humans is not enough
so who wants to jump in here Paul you
look very interested I always listen to
leave it there's a famous old saying in
science which goes the question is what
is the question and that's a much more
profound statement than it sounds and
then often we don't once we frame the
question correctly it leads us to a
theory and finally we say oh yeah
get it now so obviously we are of the
view that we can define human uniqueness
and it all emerges as a consequence of
the single trick we have cooperation is
the penalty of kinship and so a counter
I guess the volley back to leave is do
we see other animals that engage in
large-scale cooperation independently of
kinship I believe the answer is no we
can also ask if we're not unique why do
animals live in our zoos and we don't
live in theirs right I mean I think I
think it's a very very specific reasons
to believe that uniqueness is not an
empty and illusory concept the challenge
is understanding what it might actually
be if I could go back at the barrage of
the person using projectile weapons it's
interesting that Paul sort of giving a
very loose definition of humans he's
carrying it back let's say rather
subjectively to some levels of creature
where we have as yet not found human
morphology by pushing those that
humaneness
back to nearly 2 million years you're
having to grab into morphologies that
are near human perhaps with the rise of
homo erectus or things like that
but they're not at least by a present
biological definition that biology
exceeds all of modern human variation so
you're having to accept now to exceed
even that and yet still call it human so
it's a Haverhill definition that doesn't
stand the test of a biological
definition Steven you said earlier that
you try not to get involved in
definitions of what makes do you find
this fascinating words for a living I
own to work for a dictionary yeah so
yeah I'm this conversation important and
relevant or not so much for me not so
much for a couple of reasons one of them
is that in general they generally don't
have definitions they point to things
and then your best scientific theory
indicates what the boundaries of that
class are and that fuzzy borders and
perhaps a lack of a clear definition or
are they rule rather than the exception
and I think that's especially true with
the products of evolution evolution is a
gradual process there's no point in the
lineage from the common ancestor between
chimps and modern humans where you can
say well that mom was not a human in
that trial there's a human we know that
its gradual and moreover because
evolution isn't a linear process but
rather one of a richly branching tree at
any given time you can have multiple
groups that are related to each other to
varying degrees if they get too
separated we might for convenience put
them into different biological taxonomic
categories but then sometimes they can
they can interbreed there may have been
a whole bunch of species coexist in fact
we know that I'm saying may have been we
know there were a lot a bunch of
coexisting species one of them survived
but the other ones were certainly around
and if we gave back in a time machine
we'd see lots of creatures and which
ones you want to call humans and which
ones not might be partly chauvinism the
ones that are closest to us we'll call
humans but it seems to me there isn't a
scientific hypothesis or a fact of the
matter as to which ones were humans
that's a question of how we want to use
the word human what's indisputable is
that that we are in the whole space of
features of organisms we're sitting off
in a corner without a whole lot of
surviving relatives if you go back in
time there must have been a chain
linking us to humans but now there were
just very very unusual along many
dimensions at once and that's probably
as close to a definition as we'll get to
characterize what those unusual traits
are Dean where would you like to enter
this well I think that if we want to ask
what makes us human that it's
interesting to ask what is that people
do universally that other animals do not
so we can look at humans today and we
can identify some things one of which is
grammatical language the motherese so I
think that we can begin to find things
by looking at contemporary
people and then it's as Lee said it is
problematic because when you go back in
time you can't unless we get the time
machine we can't be sure you know when
these things show up but you can make
reasoned inferences so I'm not as
pessimistic about whether or not we can
define humans or make a step towards it
another thing is that with the
reorganization of the brain it's true
brain size got bigger in it and it
reorganized and there's variation like
in Hobbit that's a advance looking
little a tiny brain so one has to
acknowledge that that variation which
adds problems to interpreting the fossil
record but something that our species
does that we don't see in any other
animal is with our language you can take
a chimp and send it to college and it'll
be a little bit of language but they
don't ask questions so the human species
is a curious one and it expresses its
curiosity by asking questions so I would
throw that into being human so I think
we look for universals to begin to get
and get at this complex question brain
can I ask actually that's the question
both of Deena and we so there have been
various claims I think most recently by
Fred's four and Christopher Dean that
there may be multiple homo species
existing contemporaneously perhaps
anchored 2.3 million or earlier in other
words suggesting the possibility of an
adaptive radiation of homo do you guys
believe that and can you comment on that
you want that first well in recent years
the concept of the hominid evolution has
become bushier part of the problem is
that you have a lot of workers out there
hunting for hominids and when they find
them they often name it a new species
and say AHA this is the one that was on
the line leading to homo sapiens forget
those other fossils and you can almost
bank on that bet on that
so the
pictures complex and we've just having
this week within the last week another
example of a new species named and the
question comes down to how do you
interpret the variation your fossils and
you can be a lumper or a splitter so
it's not an easy question
uh but I'm not an explorer who's
actually discovered for guiltily named
new species let me let me though say
something that might surprise everyone
if you think human or our species is
hard to define there's absolutely no
definition of a genus so it's actually
irrelevant on what we're calling those
fuzzy transitions between 2 and the
reason there's a problem is we haven't
defined what it is to define parameters
I would go back to it seems to me like
some of the suggestions are well let's
let's just eliminate everything that
isn't a human and whatever is left is
good enough for the definition but it's
not because we can't get into these
answers to these deep questions what is
driving all these critical behavioral
issues is it babies is it throwing rocks
at babies is it speaking badly about
babies that you're throwing rocks at we
need to box that off so we can
understand are these driving or how will
we recognize parallelisms homo play z
how do we know those have anything to do
with the origin of our species or we're
just not missing the picture from a bad
archaeological and fossil record let me
emphasize those it's important not to
surrender to a council of too much
pessimism the history of science is that
fins are pretty fuzzy at the beginning
but as you as you start to make progress
there's a reciprocal dance reinforcing
dance between theory and empirical
evidence that starts to bring things
into sharp focus I think what we all
agree that that will ultimately happen
here I think the only potential disagree
how close we are to that moment we have
some questions coming in from all over
the world
Ruta from Melbourne asks why did the
development of written language cause
humans to present the natural order of
the species as patriarchal I think
that's for you Paul right because the
guys who wrote that written language
were elite males roman legionnaires
Aztec warriors these were individuals
who were writing the story they thought
was true that is that they were ordained
by God to rule All Humans does anyone
else have a different perspective on
that there were countless there was a
lot of bookkeeping with trade which was
that the origin well that's the origin
of it language but that's not the
question why did written language
reflect patriarchy that was the
questions the accounts let's not get
into whether men are better at math I'm
good could can I ask a question though
within that there are pictographic
languages that are written and these
perhaps go back into deep time and are
perhaps related to storytelling in some
ways and how do you know men did that so
that's a really profound question what
are the things we cave drawings for
example might actually a pictographic
language I was referring to written
language as formalized document
generation in that sense we know that
that's fairly recent 5500 years or so
but yes that's a profound an interesting
questions okay Maxine from Toronto asks
what would you have to say about Studies
on grain size decreasing with
domestication and larger brains being
linked to aggression by the larger
brains lead to human uniqueness your
expert on Brees did peak with
Neanderthals in terms of size so then
they subsided a little bit and they've
leveled out to where they are now
it's unlikely that they're going to get
bigger because of the difficulties to do
with childbirth the obstetric dilemma
so the ongoing evolution and there will
be I think there is it has to do with
the reorganization of the brain in terms
of the aggression in brain size I'm not
quite sure where the questioner is
coming from males do in primates
including the human primate on average
have a little bit bigger brain so I
don't know if this was a question about
whether or not males are more aggressive
than females but the question was larger
brains being linked to aggression you
accept the premise I would just I mean I
sort of reinforce what was alluded to by
both Stephan and Paul and and Dean in
fact that you know it is probably fair
to say fairly dramatically that we are
the most peaceful at least mammal that
has ever lived in the history of this
planet don't mistake I'll see you
outside after the that the fact is is
that I think it is a mistake to
emphasize the sort of application of
technology and our ability to slaughter
lots of people perhaps with our
willingness to do so in society's
punishment for those behaviors when
we've feminized the male's we reduced
our canine size these are all markers
effectively of lowering intraspecific
violence and particularly among males
but across a whole community and then
punishing those that step out of that
line just to elaborate a little more
clearly on that I Stephen said it
correctly
not only if you put our closest living
relative
50% of chimpanzees in an appropriate
sized room like this with breeding aged
males and females are unrelated that you
would have chaos you'd have a bloodbath
right and that's true of everything let
me emphasize that both Josh Goldstein
and Steve Pinker written eloquently
about the fact that not only are we the
most peaceful of all mammals
usually maybe a low bar but that we
respected but but in fact we're getting
dramatically more peaceful over time I
highly recommend both of these
remarkable books on that subject
steena well now I watched the news in
the evening and read the newspapers in
the morning and quite often their
reports of people who for reasons to do
with their beliefs are suicide bombers
that kind of thing and so my question is
and this is fairly prevalent my question
is what happens if some of these weapons
that we've created because of our big
brains get into the hands of the wrong
person so I'm not as convinced that
everything's hunky-dory in terms of our
being peaceful today I think it's a
serious potential problem yeah I'm not
I'm not sure that whether that when we
emerged as a species we were the most
peaceful in terms of the numbers that
I'm aware from Richard Wrangham and
Michael Wilson rates of lethal violence
in pre state people peoples were
comparable to those of common
chimpanzees of wolves of stags I don't
know how many species they surveyed but
just the percentage of males that are
killed by other males of the same
species or kind of in the same ballpark
but I think that they have been coming
down and because some of our of all
capabilities including those for
cooperation and for punishing aggressors
might have outstrip other parts of human
nature namely both the ability and
tendency to engage in exploitative
violence and the ability in tendency to
engage in moralistic violence and a lot
of violence is indeed punitive it's
morally driven you don't let wrongdoers
get away with what you think of as some
infraction and that licenses vast
amounts of violence which historically
although not biologically has been in
decline or at least so I argue I'm just
thinking the people in the audience
maybe one
are we really more peaceful than horses
or dolphins
those are mammal dolphins are dolphins
are nasty and horses too at the right
time there was a beautiful picture of a
couple of them fighting there but again
I I would say the one qualification is
that animals domestic animals
particularly the humans have had
enormous influence in selecting
human-like qualities in might I say may
lower some of that but generally there's
only one bull in a field and one more
Jake Holman no location listed asks I
think Stephen this is so you're here
that's why there's no location asks at
what point does our accumulation of
knowledge hit the barrier on an
individual's cognitive abilities are we
there now Stephen is that for you what
you think I guess
well not that the its inherent to our
species that knowledge is collectively
acquired and transmitted so what an
individual can conceive of is not as
important as what the collective
enterprise of science and scholarship
has accumulate and we're certainly not
at any natural limit I think when it
comes to an individual human mind we are
bumping up against truths revealed to us
by science that are highly unintuitive
it's difficult to grasp the fine points
of quantum mechanics of relativity
scales very large scales very small
perhaps aspects of consciousness and
free will that what our best
neuroscience tells us is true is very
hard for us to swallow intuitively so
much the worst of our intuitions the
reason that we have science is that we
collectively come up with a picture of
reality that might transcend what any of
us individually could think up on our
own
let me ask closing question I came in
tonight wondering if this conversation
would just be interesting
- you know people with the human trade
of curiosity about what makes us unique
if we are unique and where those traits
would have come from or if we can put
any of this to practical use for
ourselves or society I think Paul you're
the only one in the panel who addressed
kind of understanding our human nature
well enough hopefully to avoid
destroying ourselves or the planet does
anybody else have a practical
application for this or is this what you
study just because you find it
interesting
oh no I you know probably everyone in
this room has tried to find out who
their grandparents were great
grandparents were etc and the reason
that you do that is often very
interesting to sort of soul-search why
are you interested in that one of the
reasons is even without the knowledge of
genetics and other things you know that
a part of them lies in you and that you
are the way you are because of the way
they were physically and perhaps
behaviorally which might be more
interestingly what we're doing is
paleoanthropologist is doing that for
the whole species in deep time we are
the most destructive people on this
planet at the same time we're the most
peaceful we'd love to drive things to
extinction that aren't on our own
species with very little threat of
driving our own species unfortunately to
extinction and so that's supposed to be
funny and and we need to understand the
origin of these behaviors we need to
understand what drives us and these
Sciences collectively are the only way
to do it
yeah I think the what's been emphasized
this evening is that we are a
problem-solving species where
technological species we're also a
punitive species and there are a lot of
the world's problems that we can attack
with either of these mindsets we can ask
ourselves who's to blame let's find them
and punish them or
from everything from war and peace to
economic crises or we can say let's set
this up as a problem to solve how can we
make the things we don't like less
likely without necessarily having to
find bad guys and punish them and I
think the reduction in violence and the
increase in flourishing comes from
treating our problems as problems rather
than as sins with villains who who ought
to be punished okay yeah I think it's
great that we have people contemplating
these questions and worrying about our
future and where we're going to go and
we academics can sit here and discuss it
but if I think one thing that I would
like to see happen I don't know if it
well if I like to see people politicians
and world leaders become more
knowledgeable about these kinds of
discussions so that they might apply
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]